bonsoir qui suis-je
c'est la question que je me suis posée
longtemps que je me pose encore
d'ailleurs et vous allez me dire à
presque 50 ans ça sera peut être bien un
moment donné je réponde à cette question
qui suis-je
le souci c'est que ce serait bien plus
facile de bâtir son identité parce que
c'est bien de cela qu'il est question la
construction identitaire
ça serait bien plus facile de construire
son identité s'il n'y avait pas sur
notre route tout un tas de miroir placé
là pour servir de fausses pistes
nous sommes tous des miroirs les uns
pour les autres
des miroirs qui ne reflète pas toujours
une bonne image de celui que l'on a en
face de nous exemple c'était en cm1 d'un
instit dont le métier est quand même de
vendre du savoir à des élèves
il est payé pour ça à sète incite à
utiliser toute son intelligence à me
faire comprendre à quel point j'étais
con eliezer le jour où les crétins
voleront tu seras chef d'escadrille nous
sommes des miroirs les uns pour les
autres
le truc c'est que même les gens qui nous
sont le plus proches peuvent être des
miroirs un peu des formes
moi je suis né dans une famille
guadeloupéenne mes parents sont de la
guadeloupe ils sont arrivés en france
métropolitaine dans les années 60
et moi je suis né à paris xviie le truc
c'est que ma mère
voulait absolument que nous soyons
intégrer j'ai le sentiment quand j'y
pense comme ça que mes parents leur
intégration un pas été super simple
alors pour eux l'intégration ça passait
par la rupture
la césure totale avec la guadeloupe la
culture guadeloupéenne pour que je sois
un français et à part entière et pour
être un français à part entière
il faut pas parler le créole comme ça et
non le lot créole c'est enfin le
français comme ça et parler le créole ça
va me donner un accent un accent qui qui
montre à quel point je suis pas éduqué
parce que si je suis éduqué je vais
parler de français comme ça à des spa
avec son bien
j'ai grandi et puis il se trouve que
plus tard j'ai eu ce besoin de d'aller
en guadeloupe et je suis lié trois ans
rentrait dans un magasin tenu par un
guadeloupéen un guadeloupéen installé
depuis cinq générations en guadeloupe
île et libanais d'origine
et quand il parle aux français il parle
comme ça et donc je lui dit en créole
les ottawa - karanka div
quand il est pour quand tu me vois
qu'est ce que tu dis qu'est ce que je
suis pour toi désolé ma boucle d'oreille
et il me dit me répond 21 étrangers non
non ce n'est pas un étranger t1
négropolitain alors je vous explique le
négropolitain est un terme qui a été
conçue exprès pour des gens comme moi
disons noir a priori mais qui ont cette
culture blanche parce qu'ils sont
installés en france
donc quand on est en guadeloupe et qu'on
est de culture blanche en gros on est
humble en miroir miroir mais tu déconnes
mon beau miroir il ya une histoire
j'avais pas prévu de vous raconter mais
je veux vous la raconter maintenant
puisque hélios ne vous a enfin
les news vous a livré sa folie gêné pour
la livrer ben moi je vais pas me gêner
pour vous livrer cette histoire et
s'avère que moi donc pour les
guadeloupéens je suis blanc mais j'ai
découvert très tôt en allant à l'école
que j'étais noir
ça n'a pas mis très longtemps parce que
en fait je ne savais pas que j'étais
noir
je n'étais pas un sujet à la maison mes
parents on peut dater noir non tout le
monde l'était le truc et que j'arrive à
l'école et je voulais dit ma mère
c'était super important que je sois les
traits un donc j'ai appris à lire très
tôt finalement j'ai appris à écrire mais
un crayon pour écrire un pour dessiner
pardon pinceau pour peindre je n'avais
jamais eu ça entre les mains
j'arrive première semaine d'école j'ai
quatre ans et on me met derrière un
pupitre pour pouvoir dessiner pour
pouvoir faire de la peinture
alors tous les autres enfants tous mes
camarades eux avaient déjà tenu un stylo
avait déjà dessiné dorment ils ont
dessiné des papas des mamans des maisons
moi j'ai pris la première peinture qui
passait et puis le souci que c'est que
la peinture était noir l'instit vient
derrière mon pupitre et se met en colère
dit mais c'est quoi ça as tu aimes le
noir petit negro et ben tiens et me
peint le visage en noir
véridique 4 en première semaine d'école
eux
ça met en forme alors les autres sont
des miroirs des miroirs pour nous le
problème c'est que quand ces miroirs
sont dotés de préjugés sont dotés de
peur sont dotés également de fantasmes
est-ce qu'on peut compter sur eux pour
se forger une identité
encore une chose que je n'avais pas
prévu c'est une citation mais patrick
qui va passer juste après moi dans sa
grande bonté mon a prévu une et il dit
le paradoxe enfin c'est pas lui qui le
dit c'est gaston bachelard le paradoxe
de la condition humaine c'est que l'on
ne peut devenir soi-même que soul
influence des autres alors oui on va
utiliser les miroirs mais en faisant
preuve d'esprit critique et pour
l'esprit critique
on va faire appel à mon ami franz fanon
frantz fanon c'est un écrivain écrivain
psychiatre psychiatre et écrivain
martiniquais et l'essentiel de son
travail était de réfléchir sur les
conséquences de la colonisation sur les
individus il a écrit deux ouvrages
majeurs le premier peau noire masques
blancs et le second les damnés de la
terre dans peau noire masques blancs
il nous précise qu' il faut sortir dieu
regard du colonisateur
en effet le colonisé et le colonisateur
ont un même problème
le problème est qu'il se voit à travers
le regard plein de préjugés du
colonisateur
il est donc important de faire preuve
d'esprit critique pour sortir de ce
regard qui enferme
et depuis les années 1990 il ya plein de
gens qui ont pris conscience de cela et
nous assistons à un développement de
personnes qui s'insurgent qui se
révoltent et qui ont décidé de mettre en
évidence leurs particularités de
revendiquer leur identité le souci c'est
que une particularité est devenue une
identité
je suis homosexuel je suis une femme je
suis une femme noire
je suis un musulman s'avère que moi
quand j'étais petit par exemple mes amis
musulmans mais bien c'était porter le
voile ce genre de choses c'est que ce
n'est pas une question mais le ranger a
été tellement puissant tout au long des
années 80 que dans les années 90 sont
dit mais ouais je peux pas être français
mais il me faut une identité
bizarrement on a vu les choses se
précisent et sur le plan religieux
il se trouve que moi quand j'étais plus
jeune quand j'avais moins jeunes adultes
j'étais avec des dt pote antillais à
paris 130 boulevard de l'hôpital et se
trouve qu' aucun d'entre eux n'avait de
culture véritablement créé en mai
on est ce besoin de trouver cette
identité fait alors on s'est mis à
parler le français comme sa marque et
notre identité
et puis quand on se croisait ont dit des
andouilles ou faits mais affirme bac en
insistant bien sur le buzz
et puis ce petit accent créole qu'on
mettait sur le lenglen
ce petit accent alors c'est intéressant
de voir que finalement on ne parlait pas
créole en aurait plus le lire en créole
mais on à utiliser l'anglais mettre
l'accent sur une caractéristique est ce
que ça fait mon identité est ce que
parce que je revendique d'être maroc
est-ce que heureux parce que je
revendique d'être une femme d'être un
asiatique d'être un portugais ja soit
mon identité est ce que au contraire je
ne suis pas en train de prendre le même
chemin qu'initialement est-ce que je ne
suis pas tout simplement en train de
m'insurger contre le regard du
colonisateur alors vous allez me dire
pourquoi il parle de colonisateurs nous
on n'est pas colonisé et tout bien
réfléchi sont un petit peu colonisé
s'est occupé peuple et exploiter un
territoire étranger
votre cerveau n'est-il pas un territoire
que certains essayent de coloniser
régulièrement
est-ce que vous n'allez pas les
publicitaires qui essayent de grappiller
régulièrement sur votre cerveau pour le
colonisé et puis l'éducation est-ce que
c'est pas aussi une façon de coloniser
votre cerveau de vous priver d'un
certain esprit critique qui vous
permettraient parfois
de remettre en question certaines choses
qui ont été transmises de manière qui
vous sont transmises et que vous ne
remettez pas en compte en cause par
exemple on dit tout le temps que les
français enfin les ancêtres des français
sont les gaulois moi ma famille mes
parents ma mère ont appris que mon père
aussi
ils ont appris que leurs ancêtres
étaient gaulois ça on a compris pour
nous c'est pas très juste mais pour vous
qui est normand pour les bretons pour
les savoyards
pour les niçois pour les catalans pour
les basques est ce que c'est vrai est ce
que cette idée que les français sont
gaulois c'est une idée qui a toujours
été en vogue en france
est-ce que les rois de france ne pensais
pas qu'il descendait de clovis le roi
franc est ce que on remet ces questions
la couse quand on pense notre identité
il se trouve que frantz fanon nous a
laissé un témoignage nous a laissé des
enseignements pour nous aider à remettre
en cause le la vision du colonisateur
celui qui essaye de prendre le pouvoir
sur notre cerveau pas en s'insurgeant
mais en se libérant complètement comment
faire pour se libérer
eh bien d'abord on va s'informer
vous l'avez vu tout à l'heure s'informer
c'est extrêmement important c'est ce que
moi j'ai fait j'ai commencé tout d'abord
à lire à comprendre ce qui est l
histoire des antilles ces histoires
qu'on ne m'avait pas transmises ni à
l'école ni mes parents ensuite j'ai posé
des questions à ma famille mes oncles
mes tantes par an malheureusement mes
grands parents je n'ai pas eu le temps
de leur poser des questions
et puis ensuite j'ai un
frantz fanon j'ai lu edouard glissant
j'ai lu plein d'auteurs antillais pour
me faire une idée
et puis je suis parti en guadeloupe et
là j'ai découvert que ben je suis noir
ouais mais 100% français 100% entier et
en plus de cela
cerise sur le gâteau j'ai dans mes
ascendance des esclaves mais aussi des
propriétaires d'esclaves des blancs
comment on fait pour gérer ça j'ai un
ancêtre juifs j'ai un ancêtre indien en
gros dans mon identité c'est le bordel
absolue mais je refuse d'être réduit au
simple fait que je sois noir
je pense que nous devons tous refusé
d'être réduit à une caractéristique
nous sommes plus qu'une caractéristique
nous sommes des entités il y à un auteur
dont je viens de vous parler qui
s'appelle edouard glissant martiniquais
qui est réfléchi sur le tout monde le
tout le monde c'est un monde globalisé
où chacun va se mettre à la place de
l'autre et ça m'a fait penser à cette
expression qu'on utilise en créole c'est
pour dire une pour définir une personne
pour te dire que voilà c'est une
personne on va dire c'est au moon et
pour dire ça c'est un enfant on va dire
c'est en ti moun
il se trouve que le créole à base
lexicale français c'est une langue qui
est inspiré de langues africaines mais
aussi du normand et du breton des
langues du xviie siècle et en normands
pour dire monde on dit mund donc je
suppose que le mot moon viendrait de
mund donc en gros vous êtes
on moon vous êtes un monde un enfant est
un petit monde en devenir
walesa non vous êtes des mondes à
découvrir
vous êtes des mondes ça veut donc dire
que dans plein plein plein d' espaces de
votre personnalité
il ya peut-être des zones en friche des
endroits que vous n'avez pas visité
aussi la construction identitaire n'est
pas quelque chose qui s'arrête à un
moment donné ça se perpétue tout au long
de notre vie nous découvrons au fur et à
mesure ces zones que nous avons laissé
en friche pour pouvoir nous construire
notre identité
aussi la prochaine fois que je viendrais
que je vous dirai qui suis-je
vous me direz tout simplement ou si on
moon merci